اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
هدنه السودان تكشف اهوال الحرب جثث في
الشوارع عمليات سرقه ونهب مستشفيات
وجامعات مدمره
اوكرانيا تعلن ان الهجوم المضاد قريب
وتجدد حاجتها للمقاتلات وروسيا تحمي
بيوجراد
بكين تحذر طوكيو وتنتقد سياسه واشنطن
بممارسه الاكراه الاقتصادي ضد الشركات
الصينيه
وازمه سقف الدين الامريكي قد تضع الاقتصاد
امام سيناريوهات مخيفه فوضى وربما ركود
عالمي
اهلا بكم هشه في يومها الاول وصامده بحذر
في يومها الثاني الهدنه في السودان منحت
في الساعات الاخيره بعد التحذيرات
السعوديه الامريكيه الاخيره بضروره
الالتزام بها منحت السودانيين فرصه
لالتقاط الانفاس قليلا لكنها كشفت بعضا من
مخلفات الحرب مسؤولون في الامم المتحده في
السودان نقلوا عن شهود عيان ان المشهد
كالتالي جثث ملقاه في الشوارع اوضاع صحيه
صعبه في المستشفيات ومنازل تنهب وتسرق
وهاربون الى اوضاع اصعب روايات وصفها
المسؤولون بالمفزعه ترافق معها تحذيرات من
المفوضه الاممي للاجئين من ارتفاع اعداد
الفارينه من السودان الى الدول المجاوره
لنحو 300 الف داعيا الى ضروره توفير
مساعدات عاجله لدعم الدول المستضيفه
[موسيقى]
اذا هل تثبت الهدنه ام لا الشارع السوداني
يشكك ولا يستبعد بعض الخروق الطفيفه لكن
في استطلاع اجرته العربيه في الخرطوم
واندرمان يبدو ان ما يثير خشيه المواطنين
هي عمليات السرقه والنهب المستمره
سوق في هدوء لكن ما زالت النهب والسلب
والفوضى يعني منتشره بينكسر فعلا ما في
خروقات كثيره وحتى الفروقات يعني لو حصلت
بيكون خفيفه وبتكون يعني غير ممنهجه او
غير مثلا مقصوده في اكثر من 12 هدنه
تنفيذ صح وحتى اللسه حاليا وخشن فيها
المبادراتها من السعوديه وامريكا
حصل اخترناه بعض الساعه عشره بنفس شرق
النيل المواطنين
13 يوم ولا كم يوم الليل ولا قريب الشهر
ما تحركوا الناس تمشي
السوق مقفل امشي السوق الشعبي تلقى الخضار
البيت واللحم البايت
معنى من ام درمان الصحفي في مكتب العربيه
في السودان شهدي نادر اهلا بك معنا شهدي
اذا ما اخر ما رصدتموه حول الهدوء الحذر
في السودان هل ما زالت الخروقات قائمه هل
ما زال المواطنين يعني يخشون الخروج الى
الشوارع وممارسه حياتهم بشكل طبيعي
نعم فاطمه يمكن القول بان الحذر في مدينه
ام درمان حتى هذه اللحظه هو سيد الموقف
بعد الدولمه اصواتنا المدفعيه التي كانت
فجر هذا هذا اليوم اصوات المضادات التي
كانت مسموعه في عده مناطق في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري اسواق القصف المدفعي الان
هناك يمكن ان نقول بان هناك هدوء حذرا
يسود مدينه ام درمان منذ طلوع شمس هذا
اليوم منذ شروق الشمس ولا الاوضاع تبدو
هذه على اصوات اشتباكات حتى متقطعه مثل ما
كانت تجري خلال يوم امس هناك حركه في
الشارع اصطفاف للمواطنين امام المخابز
للحصول على الخبز محاولات شراء بالحاجات
الاساسيه من المحاله التي بالقرب من
المساكن كذلك هناك حركه في الاسواق
الطرفيه على مستوى بيع الخضر بيع الفاكهه
وخلا
طيب الشهدي ماذا عن حركه الطيران يعني كنت
ذكرت لنا في النشره السابقه بان شهود عيان
نقلوا لك بانه كان هناك في بعض المناطق
يعني حركه جويه للطائرات الحربيه
نعم هي طائره استصلاح حلقت فجر هذا هذا
اليوم في شمالي مدينه ام درمان وكذلك في
مدينه الخرطوم البحري بعدها سمع ذوي القصف
المدفعي ولكن هناك غياب بشكل اكثر حديقه
في مدينه درمان للطيران الحربي المقاتل
منذ يوم امس لم نشهد اي طلعات جويه في
مدينه ام درمان لم نستمع الى اصواتنا
المقاتلات تحلق جهه او
ذهابا هنا في في المدينه هناك طائره
استطلاع حلقت صباح هذا اليوم ومن ثم كان
القصف المدفعي الذي نقلته في
خلال ساعات خلال ساعات الصباح الاولى ولكن
الان الاجواء تبدو هادئه حتى لا يوجد اي
تحليق لا لطيران استطلاع ولا هكذا الى
طيران حربي شكرا جزيلا لك من ام درمان
الصحفي في مكتب العربيه في السودان شاهدي
نادر
رحله محفوفه بالمخاطر تلك التي يسلكها
الفارون من اعمال العنف والمعارك الى جنوب
السودان من منطقه مايونغا براجا تحديدا
وصل نحو 5000 النازح هربوا من الاشتباكات
ليقعوا خلال الرحله في فخ عصابات ومسلحين
مجهولين فتعرض كثير منهم لعمليات سلب ونهب
وضرب فيما اشتكى اخرون من انعدام
المساعدات الانسانيه
كانما كتب عليهما الفرار فروا من هذه
المنطقه قبل نحو سبع سنوات نتيجه الحرب
التي شهدها جنوب السودان والان يعودون
اليها نتيجه الحرب جاريه في السودان وما
بين الحربين قصص تحكى
تحركنا ووقعنا في كمين بتاعه نحب مصلح في
عربيه لاندكروزر
والحاجات اللي كنا جايين بها كلها ان شاء
الله السراير والعنوان المهم منطلقات كلها
وحتى يتعرضنا
الرجال نسوان المعاناه هي السمه المتلازمه
لهم فمنذ وصول نحو خمسه الاف شخص الى هذه
المنطقه خلال فتره الاشتباكات في السودان
يعيش معظمهم من دون اي مساعدات
والله هذا من المدينه هنا حاجه
مخاوف من نوم اخر تشغل بال الفارينه من
نيران الاشتباكات وتعقيدات الرحله فلا امن
في الطريق ولا طعام في هذا المكان
كيف يكون استقبال او هنا
تبقى نيران المعاناه اقل رحمه من نيران
الاشتباكات فقط ما يحتاجه حاول هو الطعام
المئه من الفارين من مواطنين جنوب السودان
يتم على التوطين هنا في هذه المنطقه بعد
ما اجبرتهم الاشتباكات التي تشهدها
السودان
ولسان حالهم يقول
اعطينا الطعام
جنوب السودان
من القاهره معنا المحلل السياسي السوداني
عمار عوض اهلا بكم معنا سيد عمار بدايه
لنتحدث عن ما يشاهدناه من خروقات للهدنه
يوم امس وفي ظل ذلك وفي ظل الهدوء الحذر
الذي يسود المشهد حاليا في السودان الى اي
مدى يمكن ان نتوقع ونتفائل بثبات هذه
الهدنه
نعم هذه الهدنه ليس هنالك من خيار سوى ان
تستمر لان المقابل بالنسبه لها هو دخول
البلاد في موجه فوضى وعنف اكبر من التي
مضت والتي ربما
تاكيد ستؤثر حتى على الطرفين المتقاتلين
بحيث انه ربما تخرج الازمه من ايديهم صحيح
ان هنالك سجلت خروقات في الايام الماضيه
في يوم امس واول امس لكن مع ذلك اعتقد ان
الامر ليس بهذا السوء وانه يمكن ان يبنى
عليه للوصول لوقف اطلاق نار شامل صحيح ان
في الخرطوم كانت اقل نسبيا لكن في
الولايات امس في منطقه الاوبيض ومعروف
لماذا الصراع في منطقه اللبيض
متعلق بمطار اللبيض الذي هو مطار يتوسط
السودان او ولايه تتوسط السودان تفصل ما
بين دارفور ايضا الصراع في منطقه الجنينه
مفهوم لان الجنينه لديها ارتباطات او
لانها تنفتح على الحدود الجاديه هنالك
ايضا صراعات قبليه لكن يبعث على القلق هو
التقارير التي تحدثت على ان قوات الدعم
السريع دخلت في مواجهه مع القوه المكلفه
بحفاظ على حياه المدنيين وهي قوى تضم عدد
كبير من حركات الكفاح المسلح الموقعه على
سلام جبة لان ذلك يفتح باب من جهنم
باعتبار ان هذه القوه التي لم تكن طرفا في
الصراع الان يتم جرها نتيجه للواقع
الموجود في دارفورد نتيجه
يتعرضون لهذه الجهات رغم الهدنه
نعم رقم
الهدنه الموجوده هنالك صراع سجل بشكل اعنف
في الاطراف السودان اذا كان في دارفور او
اذا كان في شمال كردفان وده معكوس على
الواقع العمليات ذلك يعني ان الصراع ربما
ينتقل الى ولايات اخرى ربما يكون مدخل
دخول قوات او اطراف جديده الى الصراع
سابق لوحت بعقوبات لاي خروقات او تعديات
يعني يبدو كما تذكر ان الدعم السريع يعني
يقوم باعتداءات وخروقات لاي هدنه او
الهدنه هذه الحاليه بالتالي هل يمكن ان
يقع عليهم العقوبات الامريكيه التي لوحت
بها
نعم الولايات المتحده لديها حزمه من
العقوبات الحزمه العقوبات التي معروفه عن
انها تستخدمها تبدا من العقوبات المتعلقه
بتجميد الحسابات
الدعم السريع لديه امبراطوريه ماليه كبيره
جدا يمكن ان تتاثر
المنع من السفر ولكن اعتقد في الظروف
الحاليه قاده الدعم السريع ليس لديهم رغبه
ربما في او لن تؤثر عليهم مساله الحظر من
السفر لكن او يعني لا يخافون اذا من وقوع
العقوبات عليهم من الجانب الامريكي سيد
عمار طيب لنتحدث قليلا عن الجانب الانساني
وما يتعرض له المواطنين من يعني نهب وسرقه
وضرب واذى حقيقه من مجموعات وعصابات
يصفونها بالمجهوله كيف يمكن السيطره على
هذا الانفلات على هذا الاذى الذي يتعرضون
له
تجفيف اسباب العنف اذا كانت ما بين قوات
الدعم السريعي والجيش الدخول في عمليه وقف
اطلاق نار يعتد به ان يقوم كل طرف من
الاطراف بواجبه اتجاه حمايه المناطق التي
موجود فيها ان يكف غاده الدعم السريع
وجنودهم من دخول بيوت المواطنين وسرقه
اموالهم وغيرها ده كله ممكن اذا تم بناء
صيغه عبر اللجان المشتركه الخاصه
بالمراقبه يمكن ان تلعب القوتين دور في
منع الذين يمكن ان يدخلوا لكن عزيزتي دعني
اقول امرا مهما ان الذي يجري في بلادنا
السودان اذا لم يتم احتوائه او البناء
هدنه بالضغوطات او بترقيب او بترهيب او
غيره ههه اسف
ربما تقود لي امتلات في الاوضاع وهذه اخر
الجيوش المنظمه الموجوده في منطقتنا
العربيه بالتالي انا افهم سرعه تحرك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومصري لاحتواء هذه الهزمه
لانهما الوحيدين الذين يعرفون قيمه ان
يكون هنالك جيشا سودانيا علمه السوداء
السعوديين عبر حرب اليمن كان السودانيين
هم الوحيدين
الجانب السعودي والمصري وحتى الامريكي
يسعون يعني بشكل حثيث وكبير لمحاوله يعني
حلحله هذه الازمه وربما التوصل الى وقف
نار شامل شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره المحلل
السياسي السوداني عمار عوض
النهب مشاهدينا لم يطل المواطنين النازحين
فحسب بل طال ايضا الجامعات والصروح
التعليميه والثقافيه في السودان عمليات
التخريب ونير نيران الحرب طالت اكبر
مكتبات البلاد ودمرت اهم كتبها ومخطوطاتها
النادره
تاريخ بات رمادا نيران حولت العلم الى
ظلام هويه فقدت في مسكنها مكتبات حرقت بعد
ان احتفظت بعشرات المخطوطات والكتب
النادره لعشرات الاعوام استقوت النار هنا
على جامعه المشرق الشهيره لدى ابنائها
استقرت في قلبها لساعات ليلا فلا بردا ولا
سلامه تغيرت ولم تعد حافظه للتاريخ كما
عهدها السودان
ست جامعات في الخرطوم التهمتها النيران
اغلبها يمثل رمزيه كبيره لاعوام طويله
لاكتنازها كتبا نادره بلغات عده تباها بها
اهلها
قبل الاستهداف بالحرق تحطيم وعمليات سرقه
ونهب للممتلكات الماديه لا المعنويه
لجامعه ام درمان وغيرها استهداف واضح
للصروح التعليميه في الايام القليله
الماضيه ما وصفه مثقفون بطعمه للذاكره
السودانيه غذاء السالم العربيه
نتحدث بعض الفاصل عنه
من تسلل الى الجراد الحدوديه هل هي جماعات
اوكرانيه ام روسيه مناهضه للكرملين نعرف
بعد قليل
احييكم من جديد على عكسي ما تردد عن نقص
كبير في الذخيره لدى الجيش الاوكراني اعلن
رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
اعلن في تصريحات صحفيه انك لديها ما يكفي
من الاسلحه وان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
الذي طال انتظاره سيبدا قريبا لكن لم ينفي
رئيس الاستخبارات حاجه كييف الى مزيد من
الاسلحه خصوصا المقاتلات
من كييف معنى الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك
معنا محمد اذا يعني كيف نفهم هذه
التصريحات
المتناقضه
والانباء المتناقضه وحتى التلويح المستمر
بهجوم اوكراني مضاد قريب يعني كيف نفهم
ذلك هل هناك بالفعل هجوم اوكراني مضاد ام
هو مجرد تلويح وتخويف
لا يعني ان راينا المجريات منذ حوالي
ثلاثه او اربعه اشهر تستعد القوات
الاوكرانيه للقيام بهجوم مضاد لاستعاده
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وكما قال
بهدانوف وهو رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه قال ان اوكرانيا الان لديها
الحد الادنى من المخزون الذي يكفي للقيام
بهذه العمليه الحد الادنى هو ما يكفي ولكن
اوكرانيا تحتاج الى مزيد ومزيد من العتاد
العسكري والزخائر خاصه ذخائر مدافع التي
يعني خلال ثلاثه او اربعه اشهر كانت تعاني
اوكرانيا الى حد ما نقص على الجبهات ولكن
تم تغطيه هذا النقص بفعل يعني تاخير بعض
الدول الاوروبيه تزويد اوكرانيا بفعل يعني
بيروقراطيات وزارات الدفاع الغربيه ولكن
هذه تم تجاوزها بفعل يعني اللقاءات وايضا
الاجتماعات التي كانت تجربه بين وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني
الغربيين الان تم معالجه السبل او الطرق
اللوجستيه وخطوط الامداد من الدول الغربيه
للجيش الاوكراني لتصل يعني الزخائر
والسلاح الى الجبهات الى شرق اوكرانيا
بسرعه بشكل يعني امني بحمايه امنيه كبيره
الان يعني تستعد القوات الاوكرانيه وتجري
اللمسات الاخيره على الهجوم المضاد هذا
الهجوم الذي سيقلب الطاوله سيغير وجوه
يعني العمليات في شرق اوكرانيا الجيش
الاوكراني الذي كان منذ حوالي يعني فتره
سبعه او ثمانيه اشهر في خطوط دفاعيه
سينتقل خلال هذا الهجوم المضاد الى الى
عمليات هجوميه هذه العمليات الهجوميه
تحتاج الى غطاء جوي لذلك كانت مناداه
القوات الاوكرانيه وحتى الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيدنسكي للحلفاء الغربيين بضروره
تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات وبحسب ما يتداول
ايضا عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ووسائل
الاعلام اوكرانيه ان يعني طيارين
اوكرانيين بداوا بالفعل اجراء تدريبات على
استخدام طائرات اف 16 التي ستكون في اوكر
انيا خلال اشهر قليله بحسب يعني جوزيف
بوريل المتحدث
الاوروبي الذي قال ان يعني معظم يعني
قرارات الاتحاد الاوروبي او الدول
الاوروبيه وحلف الناتو هي تزويد اوكرانيا
ودعمها لمواجهه الغاز الروسي للاراضي
الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا لك من كيف الصحفي
محمد البابا
في تطورات الوضع في بيل جراده الروسيه
المتاخمه لاوكرانيا اعلن حاكم المقاطعه ان
منطقتين في المقاطعة تعرضت ليلا لهجمات
لمسيرات مما تسبب في اندلاع حريق في
منزلين واشار الحاكم الى ان الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه اسقطت عددا كبيرا من
المسيرات ليله امس مضيفا الى ان سكان
المناطق التي تعرضت للهجوم في منطقه بيلجر
الروسيه اعيد توطينهم في مناطق اخرى
بالجراد عموما مشاهدينا تشهد توترا منذ
ايام فقد اعلنت روسيا انها شنت اليومين
الماضيين عمليه اسمتها مكافحه الارهاب
حاصرت خلالها مسلحين عبروا الحدود من
اوكرانيا وقتلت اكثر من 70 منهم واعادت
الباقين طبعا موسكو اجلت السكان من تسعه
قرى او تسعه قرى حدوديه خلال العمليه لكن
من هي هذه الجماعه المسلحه التي تسللت الى
الحدود الروسيه موسكو قالت انهم مسلحون
اوكرانيون بينما قالت انهم ينتمون الى
مجموعتين شبهه عسكريتين مناهضتين للكرملين
واوضح مسؤولون اوكرانيون انهم مواطنون روس
من فيلق يعمل بشكل مستقل ويسعى الى انشاء
منطقه امنيه للاوكرانيين من موسكو مع
مراسله العربيه كاتيا تعمى للحديث ومزيد
عن ذلك اهلا بك معنا كاتيا ايضا بدايه هذه
الجماعه التي تسللت ما حقيقتها من هم
تحديدا
مرحبا بك فاطمه حقيقه وفقا للروايه
الرسميه التي تتحدث عنها موسكو طبعا هم
هذه الجماعه هي تعود القوات الاوكرانيه
التي وصل عددها الى نحو 80 فردا تسللت الى
الاراضي الروسيه وبالتالي كانت روسيا قد
اعلنت على خلفيه ذلك عمليه مكافحه
الارهاب في هذه المنطقه ولكن الدفاع كانت
خرجت وتحدثت انه تم القضاء على سبعين منها
او لا وطرد عشره منهم محاصرتهم الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه والتي كما تحدثت انها
تتابع عمليه القضاء عليهم ولكن على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه كانت قد تحدثت روسيا
انها قامت بالغاء نظام مكافحه الارهاب
الارهاب الذي اعلنته على في المدينه على
خلفيه هذا الحادث ولكن استمرارا طبعا
للهجمات التي نشهدها في هذه المنطقه
الحدوديه الساخنه التي تبعد نحو 40
كيلومترا عن اوكرانيا كان هناك استمرار في
هذه المدينه باستخدام المسيرات كما تحدث
حاكم منطقه التي طبعا هي تستمر على مدى
يومين بالاضافه الى تسلل هناك هجمات عبر
المسيرات ولكن كما تحدث حاكم هناك اسئله
كثيره يطرحها المواطنون وبما فيهم هو ايضا
الى وزاره الدفاع الروسيه كيف استطاعت هذه
المجموعه التسلل الى الاراضي الروسيه
وطبعا دعا لان يكون هناك تعزيز لقوات
الروسيه على الحدود بما انها منطقه اولا
منطقه ساخنه وتستمر عمليات الهجوم وهذا هو
الهجوم الثاني او التسلل الثاني من نوعه
فاطمه الذي شاهدت شهدته هذه المدينه خلال
الفتره الثلاث اشهر الاخيره طبعا
نظرا لانها حدوديه وقريبه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه فمن السهل التسلل عبرها الى
الاراضي الروسيه فاطمه شكرا جزيلا لك من
موسكو مراسله العربيه
حول عدم تجميد النزاع في اوكرانيا قائلا
انه يوافقها في هذا المجال مضيفا ان روسيا
تنظر فقط في امكانيه انجاز العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه بها ضفي ضمان مصالحها
وتحقيق الاهداف التي حددتها اما من خلال
عملياتها او بالوسائل الاخرى المتاحه
اكد رئيس الوزراء الروسي ميخائيل ميشو
ميشوستين على ان العلاقات بين روسيا
والصين في مستوى عال غير مسبوق وتتميز
باحترام مصالح بعضهما البعض مشددا ان
البلدين تعرضتا لضغط عقوبات غير قانونيه
من قبل الغرب وتعتزم روسيا والصين توقيعه
مجموعه من الاتفاقيات الثنائيه في اطار
الزياره التي يجريها رئيس الوزراء الروسي
ميخائيل مشوستين الى العاصمه الصينيه بكين
العلاقات بين روسيا والصين اليوم في مستوى
عال غير مسبوق وتتميز باحترام مصالح
بعضهما البعض والرغبه في الاستجابه
المشتركه للتحديات الجديده المرتبطه
باضطراب المتزايد على الساحه الدوليه وضغط
عقوبات غير قانوني من قبل الغرب
حددت القرارات التي اعتمدها الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين والرئيس الصيني في مارس
الماضي مبادئ توجيهيه لبناء التعاون في
ثمانيه مجالات ذات اولويه وقد بدا العمل
المنسق من خلال الحكومات لتنفيذ هذه
الاتفاقيات
ذلك قال وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي
لافروب قال ان الغرب ينظر الى الصين
وروسيا على انهما خصمان استراتيجيان
وتهديد قائم بينما يقوم بينما ما يقوم به
الغرب بارسال الاسلحه المدمره لاوكرانيا
سيؤدي الى حرب نوويه بحسب لافروف
الخارجيه الصينيه عرضت عن رفضها الشديد
لمواصفته بسياسه الاكراه الاقتصادي ضد
الشركات والافراد الصينيين في الولايات
المتحده وقالت المتحدثه باسم الوزاره هذه
السياسات مرفوضه وتتعارض مع القوانين
الدوليه التي تحكم العلاقات التجاريه من
جهه اخرى قالت الخارجيه الصينيه انها
تعارض خطط اليابان لانشاء مكتب اتصالات
تابعا لحلف الناتو على اراضيها
مستمرون معكم ونتابع 82 مليون دولار اختفت
من شركه العراقيه اين ومتى هيئه النزاهه
تحقق
هدنه السودان تكشف اهوال الحرب جثث في
الشوارع عمليات سرقه ونهب مستشفيات وجامعه
مدمره
اوكرانيا تعلن ان الهجوم المضاد قريب
وتجدد حاجتها للمقاتلات وروسيا تحمي
بكين تحضر طوكيو وتنتقد سياسه واشنطن
بممارسه الاكراه الاقتصادي ضد الشركات
الصينيه
ازمه سقف الدين الامريكي قد تضع الاقتصاد
امام سيناريوهات مخيفه فوضى وربما ركود
عالمي
احييكم من جديد اكثر من 82 مليون دولار
اختفت من ايرادات احدى الشركات
العراقيه والتابعه لوزاره الصناعه
والمعادن هذا اخر ملفات الفساد التي كشفت
عنها هيئه النزاح العراقيه وتحقق فيها كيف
اختفت نتابع
بعد سرقه القرن التي هزت الراي العامه في
العراق كشفت دائره التحقيقات بهيئه
النزاهه العراقيه مؤخرا عن اختفاء اكثر من
82 مليون دولار من ايرادات احدى الشركات
التابعه لوزاره الصناعه والمعادن في
محافظه بابل
المبلغ المفقود اختفى في الفتره الممتده
من سبتمبر ايلول 2017 وحتى سبتمبر ايلول
2022 لكن هيئه النزاهه امتنعت عن ذكر اسم
الشركه وعدد المتورطين في هذه القضيه قضاء
العراقي ماض قدما بالتحقيق فيها من اجل
التوصل النتائج وبعد التوصل النتائج وبعد
اكمال التحقيقات سواء كان من مجلس القضاء
لاسوء كان من القضاء العراقي سواء كان من
الهيئات التحقيقيه المنبثق عن هيئه
النزاهه او الفريق الساند عند غايه يتم
الاعلان وكشف النقاب عن ماهيه المتورطين
وعن اعدادهم وعن اسم الشركات وعن حجم
الاموال التي تم اختلاسها وسرقتها اغلب
المستندات التي تحتوي الارقام والاحصائيات
الخاصه بالحسابات الختاميه لخمسه اعوام تم
اخفائها من قبل الموظفين المسؤولين عن
المشروع ما دفع هيئه النزاهه الى اعتقالهم
للتحقيق معهم في واحده من اكبر قضايا
الفساد هزه البلاد مؤخرا ربما هذا الملف
يعني حسب المعلومه انه قد يكون من زمن
لعبادي ثم الى عاد عبد المهدي ثم الى
الكاظم يعني قد يكون بين 2017 الى 2022 او
فلذلك هذا الملف لحد الان في طور جمع
المعلومات لكن الموضوع ليس غريبا عما يجري
بصوره عامه في العراق عملا باحكام الماده
نهايته العام الماضيه اعلنت هيئه النزاهه
العراقيه عن تشكيل هيئه عليا للتحقيق
بقضايا الفساد الكبرى في البلاد والتي تصل
الى 11 الف قضيه ثبت فيها تورط
605 مسؤولين بينهم 54 وزيرا من بغداد
منتظر رشيد العربيه
اقتحمت القوات الاسرائيليه مشاهدينا اليوم
مدينتي نابلس وجنين وعددا من القرى
والبلدات في الضفه الغربيه واعتقلت ثمانيه
فلسطينيين وشنت حملات تفتيش وعلى وقع هذه
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه اندلعت اشتباكات
في نابلس وفي جنين ايضا في الضفه الغربيه
وتشن اسرائيل منذ ايام حمله اعتقالات ضد
فلسطينيين في الضفه والقدس وعمليات هدم
للمنازل
[موسيقى]
الى تركيا حيث يواصل الناخبون الاتراك
والمقيمون في الخارج الادلاء باصواتهم في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه وتجاوز عدد الناخبين الاتراك في
الخارج المليون وسبعمائه الفمن باصواتهم
ومن المقرر ان تنتهي عمليه التصويت في
الممثليات الخارجيه اليوم فيما تستمر في
المعابر الحدوديه حتى الثامن والعشرين من
مايو جاري وبعد تاييد المرشح المنسحب سنان
اوغان للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لم
يستبعد مواطنون اتراك ان مساومه حصلت وراء
الكواليس بينما اعتبر البعض ان هذا الدعم
لن يؤثر على النتيجه
براي دعم سنان اوغان ليس كافيا ربما
التقوا في نقطه معينه وبسبب كون سنان
اوغان من خلفيه قوميه فمن الطبيعي دعمه
لتحالف الشعب لكنه غير كاف
عرضاغان سوف يفوز على اي حال حتى اذا فزنا
في صناديق الاقتراع سيفوز اردوغان مره
اخرى هذا واضح في كل مكان اتوقع ان سينان
اوغان دعمهم لمنفعته الشخصيه
هذا الوضع لن يؤثر على الانتخابات باي شكل
لان الناس انتخبت
ومن اردوغان لهذا السبب لا اعتقد انه
سيؤثر على الانتخابات
بالطبع حصل اتفاق معين بسبب تحالفه مع
اردوغان ربما سيعطيه مقعدا بالبرلمان او
يجعله وزيرا للداخليه لان الرجل حاصل على
دراسات عليا برايي سيعطيه موقعا جيدا
كان ذلك في تركيا اما في باكستان وبعد
قرار تمديد كفاله رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان اعلن
مسؤولون ان المتورطين في احتجاجات عنيفه
على اعتقاله سيحاكمون امام محاكم عسكريه
وفي مقابله مع العربيه اكد بابر اعوان احد
ابرز اعضاء الفريق القانوني لعمران خان
اكد ان كل القضايا التي يتجاوز عددها 145
ضد عمران خان لا اساس لها
هناك اكثر من 145 قضيه حتى الان ضد عمران
خان وان حسبنا لاختارات المدنيه ستصبح
اكثر من 160 حصلنا على كفالات ضد الاعتقال
في كافه القضايا عبر فريقنا القانوني ما
عدا هذه القضيه سواء في المحاكم العليا او
محاكم البنوك او محكمه قضايا الارهاب او
المحاكم الجنائيه لان كافه القضايا ضد
عمران خان لا اساس لها
اعوان اضاف في مقابلته مع العربيه انهم
وبعد تمديدهم باعتقال عمران خان اتجهوا
الى تشكيل لجنه قضائيه للتحقيق في اعمال
الشغب لكن عن امكانيه تشكيل محاكم عسكريه
قال انها غير ممكنه
ما جرى بالتاسع مما كان مؤسفا وسيئا وقد
نددنا بذلك لكن السؤال هو من فعل ذلك لقد
توجهنا الى المحكمه العليا الدستوريه من
اجل تشكيل لجنه تحقيق قضائيه من قضاه
المحكمه العليا للوصول الى اصل الاحداث
ومن قام باعمال الشغب فنحن لا نتبنى اي
احد مسؤول عن اي نشاط يخالف الاجنده
السلميه لعمران خان وحزب الانصاف كما
سياده القانون والعمل السياسي وفق قوانين
البلاد واخيرا لا ارى امكانيه تشكيل محاكم
عسكريه لان كافه جمعيات ونقابات المحامين
والقضاء اعلنوا رفضهم لمحاكمه المدنيين
امام محاكم عسكريه
الى الولايات المتحده حيث قال البيت
الابيض ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ورئيسه مجلس النواب كيفن وكورسي متفقان
على ان التخلف عن سداد الدين امر غير
مطروح على طاوله النقاشات وان هناك مجال
للاتفاق على السداد وشددت المتحدثه باسم
البيض الابيض كرنجون بير على ان عواقم
التخلف عن سداد الديون لاول مره ستكون
وخيمه على الشعب والاقتصاد
رغم فشل اجتماع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ورئيسي مجلس النواب كبن مكارتي بالتوصل
الى اتفاق حول سقف الدين التفاؤل موجود
الى طاوله التفاوض اكد انه ما يعملان على
التوصل الى حل وسط بشان الميزانيه قبل
الاول من يونيو
الجمهوريون القوا باللوم على الرئيس بايدن
واعاد اتهامه بالتاخر في اجراء المفاوضات
مع مكارتي واكدوا تمسكهم بشروطهم كما اوضح
زعيمهم في مجلس النواب
الذي رايناه في الايام القليله الماضيه من
جو بايدن هو الاستمرار في تضييع الوقت
وليس تقديم افكار جاده على طاوله
المفاوضات في الواقع تقديم افكار جديده
غير مالوفه الرئيس يتحدث عن زياده الضرائب
لقد اوضحنا منذ البدايه اننا لن نرفع
الضرائب
في المقابل اعتبر رئيس التجمع الديمقراطي
في مجلس النواب ان الجمهوريين محتجزون من
قبل الجناح المتطرفه في حزبهم
الديمقراطيون في مجلس النواب على
التخفيضات المدمره للمساعدات الغذائيه
للمعلمين او التخفيف يحتاج رئيس مجلس
النواب مكارثي الى ان يكون جادا الطرفان
متمسكان بشروطهما ويتبادلان التهمه حول
ازمه الدين الذي ارتفع من نحو خمسه
التريليونات دولار عام 2000 الى اكثر من
31 تريليون دولار هذا العام
اذا عدت الى الفتره التي كان فيها الرئيس
كلينتون في منصبه ثم غادره فقد ترك في
الواقع فائضا بمئات ملايين الدولارات التي
اعادها جورج w الى الاغنياء عبر التخفيضات
الضريبيه ثم بدات حرب العراق وافغانستان
بزياده العيش الى الرقم اليوم وادى الركود
عام 2008 الى تفاقم المشكله ولعل الحل
الوحيد المتبقي للازمه الحاليه وفق خبراء
هو رفع موجز لسقف الدين لفتره زمنيه محدده
لاعطاء مزيد من الوقت للطرفين لمواصله
العمل على القضيه
يدور الحديث الان في واشنطن على ان
المشرعين قد يبقون في العاصمه خلال عطله
نهايه الاسبوع الطويله التي تتزامن مع عيد
العمال من اجل التوصل الى حل للازمه حسين
الطوط العربيه واشنطن
ماذا لو تعذر التوصل لاتفاق بشان ازمه سقف
الدين الامريكي على الاقتصاد العالمي
سيناريوهات ثلاثه اختصرها الخبراء
الاقتصاديون فما بين سيء واسوا توقعات
سلبيه جنه السيناريو الاول اتفاق اللحظه
الاخيره وهنا ستتراجع الاسهم ولكن ليس
بالضروره ان يفقد الموظفون اعمالهم اما
الثاني فهو التوصل الى اتفاق ولكن بعد
الموعد النهائي هذا السيناريو قد يؤدي الى
تراجع الانفاق بشكل حاد كما قد توقف
الشركات خطط التوظيف والاستثمار وفي
السيناريو الاسوا الا وهو التخلف عن
السداد هذا بالتحديد ينبئ بفوضى عارمه في
النظام المالي العالمي وركود اشد حده من
عام 2008
للمزيد ينضموا الينا من مدينه في ولايه
ميشيغن استاذ الاقتصاد بجامعه اوكلند
الدكتور مصطفى شاهين اهلا بك معنا دكتور
اذا يعني توقعات وسناريوهات ثلاثه يعني من
احلاهما مر ربما اي هذه السيناريوهات
تتوقع بان يرجح وان يتم اتخاذه في شان
ازمه سقف الدين
اولا صباح الخير استاذه فاطمه وكل الساده
المشاهدين في العالم العربي
حابب اقول لحضرتك ان احنا الحقيقه ليست
المره الاولى ان يحدث هذه المكايده
السياسيه بين الحزب الديمقراطي والحزب
الجمهوري هنا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حول ازمه الموازنه الفيدراليه
الامريكيه لتخفيض عجز الموازنه الحقيقه
انا لا اتوقع ابدا ان الحكومه الامريكيه
او الكونجرس سيرفض رفع سقف الدين الامريكي
لان الحقيقه هيعمل مشاكل ضخمه جدا داخل
الولايات المتحده وخارج الولايات المتحده
من على سبيل المثال اذ لم تستطع الحكومه
انها توفر التدابير الماليه انها بتدفع
شهريا
السوشيال سكيورتي اللي هو مدفوعات الضمان
الاجتماعي
لملايين الامريكان كبار السن بتدفع
للمحاربين او الجنود او العسكريين
كثير جدا من نفقات بتدفع للمعلمين وغيرهم
فاذا الحكومه الامريكيه لم تستطع ان رفع
ترفع سقف الحد الامريكي حنفاجئ ان هذه
الفئات اللي بتتقادى رواتب شهريه او بعضهم
بيتقاضى معاشات شهريه هتاثر على استهلاكهم
هنلاقي اللي بيشتري سياره او اللي عليه
اقساط سياره
يرفض الكونجرس رفع حد سقف الدين ولكن متى
لان ايضا الوقت يلعب يعني دور هام جدا نعم
هو ممكن جدا للكونجرس ان هو
يقر ميزانيه انتقاليه لفتره ثلاث شهور
مثلا حتى يتم تسويه الجدال حول قضيه رفع
السقف الديني والرئيس الامريكي الحقيقه
صرح بكده قال احنا مش في قضيه عدم السداد
احنا اختلفنا الان بين قضيتين اثنين
الجمهورين عايزين يقللوا الضرائب
والديمقراط عايزين يزودوا النفقات الكلى
الامرين بالنسبه يعني الديمقراط مش عايزين
ابدا يخفضوا الضرايب عن الاغنياء وفي نفس
الوقت وفي نفس الوقت شريحه كبيره جدا التي
تؤيد الحزب الديمقراطي داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي من من اسر المتوسطه
مش الاسر الغنيه
واغلبهم ايضا وكذلك في فئه اخرى زي
المهاجرين دائما الاداره الديمقراطيات
تشجع على التعليم وزياده النفقات على
التعليم
والخدمات الاجتماعيه المرتبطه
بالام التي تعيل الاسر كثير جدا برامج
الاجتماعيه
الجمهوريين ما يحبوش كده الجمهوريه عايز
يخفض الضرائب عن الاغنياء حتى تستمر
القافله فالان
الجمهوريين ضاغطين جدا على الرئيس بيضين
لان طبعا كل ان الرئيس بايدن يوافق
الجمهوريين على تخفيض النفقات على فئات
اساسيه طبعا دي هزيمه لهم في الانتخابات
المقبله واحنا بقينا على اعتابها يعني
قدامنا سنه فالقضيه الحافي جدا لكن قضيه
التوقف عن سداد الدين هذه غير مطروحه على
الاطلاق
انهيار المنظومه الماليه العالميه بكل
تاكيد دكتور طيب يعني هذه المكايده
السياسيه كما وصفتها وهذه المكاسب
الانتخابيه التي يحاول كل طرف ان يحصل
عليها هل يمكن ان تؤدي ربما الى ركود يعني
هل هناك قلق من مخاوف من حصول ركود كما
شاهدنا في 2008 ام هذا مستبعد في هذا
الوقت لا اذا حدث بص يا استاذه فاطمه
لقوم الامريكي دي البرايت بتاع امريكا دي
العظمه بتاع امريكا ان كونك انك تتخلفي عن
السداد في ناس متربصه بامريكا الان خاصه
الصين الصينيين لو لقوا الامريكان توقفوا
عن السداد معناها فقدان الثقه في الدولار
معناها البعد تماما عن الدولار سيؤدي الى
تدهور حاد جدا داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وده فقدان لسلطاتها الدولار يا
استاذه فاطمه تم بعد اربع سنه 44 ان سيطره
الدولار انت الان جاي الصينيين او دول
اخرى بتحارب الدولار الان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تدرك ذلك تماما خاصه
خبراء الامن القومي الامريكي يعلمون تماما
مدى اهميه وقوه الدولار في الاسواق
العالميه فمعنى ان انت تتوقفي عن السداد
خلي بالك تقريبا 70% من الدين الامريكي
للمواطنين الامريكان وللفيدرا ريزرف بانك
للبنك الفيدرالي الامريكي لكن و30
يعودون الى
الحكومات او المؤسسات الدوليه هذا مش لن
يمكن الولايات المتحركه تتوقف عن سدين لان
سيكون هناك انهيار للدولار وانهيار
الدولار
حرفيا نظام عالمي جديد قضيه الكساد داخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ابدا لن يكون
بالعكس لو ان خطه الرئيس بايدن تمت فكون
ان هو يريد ان يزيد الانفاق هذا سيشجع
الاقتصاد الامريكي خلي بال حضرتك ان ولا
اول مره طبعا بعد ازمه الكورونا الاقتصاد
الامريكي خلقت 12 مليون وظيفه ومعدل
البطاله في امريكا من احسن معدلات الان
يعني معدل البطاله في امريكا الان ثلاثه
واربعه من عشره في الميه معناها ان
الاقتصاد الامريكي على اقصى قوه انتاج بل
ان هنالك كثير من الاعمال في امريكا الان
لا تجد عمال
الازمه داخليا هي بس قضيه السياسيه ستنتهي
قريبا هذا ظني على
محاولات لي اذرع شكرا دكتور مصطفى شاهين
لبقائك معنا حتى ساعات متاخره بتوقيت
ديترويد في ولايه ميشيكين والساده
الاقتصاد في جامعه اوكلين دكتور مصطفى
شاهين اشكرك مجددا
حصدت مشاهدينا قناه العربيه 38 جائزه من
بينها خمس جوائز من الفئه الذهبيه من
جوائز تالي التي تعنى بتكريم التميز في
مجال التلفزيون والفيديو
جوائز تيل العالميه الفئه الذهبيه البرامج
على خطى العرب مهمه خاصه
عسكري تاريا
[موسيقى]
التغطيات الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
تقرير بتقنيه الواقع الافتراضي من هو
بايدن
ثمان وثلاثون جائزه نصب قناه العربيه من
جوائز تالي العالميه في نسختها الرابعه
والاربعين
الجائزه التي تنظم السنويا في الولايات
المتحده تقدم لارفع الانتاجات التلفزيونيه
وتقدم في فئات ثلاث
ذهبيه وفضيه وبرونسي
الجائزه تعد واحده من اهم الجوائز
المتخصصه في مجال تقييم محتوى الفيديو
والانتاج المرئي بمشاركه خبير من مؤسسه
اعلاميه وقنوات وشركات انتاج دوليه ضمن
الفئات التي ربحت جائزه التالي خمس جوائز
ذهبيه كانت من نصيبي ثلاثه برامج وتغطيه
على الصعيد البرامج برنامج عن خطى العرب
ومهمه خاصه وعسكري تاريا اما على الصعيد
التغطيه فكانت من نصيب تغطيه الانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه وكذلك تقرير نفذ بتقنيه
الواقع الافتراضي من هو
جوائز تالي التي حازتها قناه العربيه كانت
ضمنها عشرون جائزه فضيه وثلاثه عشره جائزه
من الفئه البرونزيه
ذهبت لعدد من برامج العربيه وتغطياتها
الخاصه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والوثائقيه
وبرامجها على مواقع التواصل والتصميم
الابداعي واستخدام الواقع المعزز
في الختام نذكر بالعناوين
هدنه السودان تكشف احوال الحرب جثث في
الشوارع عمليات السرقه ونهب ومستشفيات
وجامعات مدمره
اوكرانيا تعلن ان الهجوم المضاد قريب
وتجدد حاجتها للمقاتلات وروسيا تحمي
بكين تحضر طوكيو وتنتقد سياسه واشنطن
بممارسه الاكراه الاقتصادي ضد الشركات
الصينيه
ازمه سقف الدين الامريكي قد تضع الاقتصاد
امام سيناريوهات مخيفه فوضى وربما ركود
عالمي
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات